so bro wait
oh yeah okay Siva yeah okay yeah let's
celebrate the boy real quick okay
elaborate the boy real not to go back
into hours of gambling talk but let me
just okay let me just for the listeners
okay for listeners and the Watchers
let me just say
we're gonna talk about gambling for the
next hour and 40 minutes so get over it
no no you know what's funny before you
say that can I interrupt real quick
please it's like we do these episodes
where we talk about this for 30 minutes
because we're both very passionate about
this right yeah and I go and read the
comments I don't see a single one about
gambling not negative not positive
people just don't even acknowledge it
they're like way worse I would like it
better if they didn't [__] with it you
know if they were like guys this really
sucks but it's just nothing yeah they're
like they're talking about slime machine
I'm gonna go do I'm gonna go swap the
line
or I'll just hit the thing the little
category on the bottom yeah skip that
whole second so we were talking last
week
about the boy Siva and you know I'm I'm
always a champion for his
his professional gambling because it
because hey he's a
IRS if you're listening he's a
professional Gambler now
okay okay our boy Siva is a career no no
watch your [__] tongue well he's a
career gambler
what what like how do you it's his side
hustle right aren't we all professional
gamblers yes but Siva extra professional
he's an EP wouldn't you want but wait
wouldn't you want to tell the IRS that
it's just a hobby no
nope because of your pro you pay less
taxes because if you're Pro it's a
business
and there are business expenses oh like
like traveling money yes the money you
feed into the Slime exactly expense hey
you bought some meals you're on the job
yeah okay you pay to fly to work
Okay so
uh what is considered professional
someone who has complete control over
the time money and energy they spend on
gambling see
don't we all yeah well some people don't
have control
[Laughter]
we do though yeah yeah we're very
controlled yeah very we're very
controlled by how much money we put in
the machine and we get paid every time
we gamble yeah
yeah we win yeah so technically we're
professionals right as well so anyways
I'm always I'm always a champion first
oh wait yeah wait they're considered at
low risk for addiction all right yeah
never mind
yeah
oh so we don't qualify it yeah no I'm
not even close well we're sitting with
the IRS and they go
so you're down 19 500.
every time you go no no I'm in full
control I'm in full control it seems
like you're always losing dude one of my
you know one of my best friends lives in
London yeah and like sports gambling I'm
pretty sure is illegal there right
um depends what corner you go to I
actually thought it was like
more legal there but anyways he you know
he's been kind of observing like our uh
you know gambling from afar because he's
not really into it he doesn't watch
American Sports or craft yeah and he was
like it's been really interesting
watching you guys spiral from like this
just being like a fun thing you do to
like a full-on addiction for all of you
yeah
yeah yeah and he walks past the the
corner bookies in London every day and
he goes thank [__] yeah not me yeah
exactly well you're missing out man yeah
and I know who you are you know who I'm
talking about I know who you're talking
yeah yeah let me just read their text
verbatim because you know he says it in
his London accent too are you gonna mock
him now I am yeah yeah because it pissed
me off yeah yeah oh yes let's get racist
come on racist
you know mock him
pour up some of this tonic
I've been I'm just sipping straight
tonic water premium Indian water
that's what it says premium Indian
tonic water he said it's been
interesting watching it's been
interesting watching the boys go from
social betting to endemic gambling
addiction endemic
you have to fight
and then my friend replies and goes is
it considered an addiction if you can't
lose
oh
ah
all right enough talking about this
though no oh yeah okay no so so I'm
always a champion for Siva system
and then you know in the bonus last week
we discussed his system a little bit and
naturally
Corbin had a bit of skepticism he was
like how can you how can you really and
I mentioned casually that Steve was
participating in slots tournament and
Corbin was like how does a tournament
high limit tournament high limit term
let's be clear let's be clear high limit
slots tournament yeah
so yeah I know I know and and listen I I
side with everyone in that that's a
ridiculous thing to say how the [__] can
you participate in an active strategy
but I'll get into that later this is
hilarious but
so Siva he's in this last tournament
and I'm in the middle of my virtual
therapy call
okay you know and he calls me on
telegram he never does this I gotta hang
up on him and I message him real quick
he hung up on your therapist yeah yeah
oh my boy's calling I gotta take this
yeah yeah and zoom my boy's in Vegas I
gotta handle this
poop see ya I hit him back and I say hey
man I'm you know why my therapist is
trying to like fix me or whatever
I'm just like uh-huh yeah and I'm typing
to him yeah bro
yo bro I'm in therapy what's going on
right now and it he goes LMAO sorry then
just sends a video
of a very large sum of money which we
will not disclose okay being counted up
and paid into his bare hand right and
then he just kind of holds it out and he
makes sure to show me his watch right
right in the video nice it just kind of
shakes it a little bit nice what kind of
watch do you have uh well we won't
disclose
he's a professional Gambler right we
gotta get that IRS agent back in yeah
yeah dude yeah whenever we talk about
this yeah
and he just you know and then he tells
me the amount I had to pick my jaw awful
Meanwhile your therapist he's like well
this is probably from you know when you
were a child and uh your parents used to
you're like holy [__] she's like I know
this is shocking she's like what you're
like that was it's just so on point yeah
you nailed it what a revelation truly
yeah stupendous wins
Fantasmic went wow sorry what are you
saying no I'm just saying stupendous
that you nailed that observation it was
from when I was a kid well so then Siva
you know uh he vaulted
a large chunk like a large chunk of
money this weekend and continued to play
okay had some wins had some L's but he
came away
how much
nineteen thousand five hundred
yeah yeah yeah yeah got it no we don't
know we don't know I don't know what you
don't know yeah I couldn't even you
can't read lips so I don't know so you
know
a million dollars yeah yeah
we should run up the number so when the
IRS hits them up they're like um you owe
four trillion yeah sorry it seems like
you would owe us about seven million in
back taxes where'd the rest of it go
yeah so he so he was fired up yeah
yeah so did he win the tournament
um no so the tournament he he busted out
I think in like
uh top 100 okay
so
that was the funniest part though so I
go dude
what is your strategy he goes none I
just press the button fast
so that yeah so we were wrong no no
you're definitely right okay no but I
was more I press the button fast yeah
hilarious it just jammed it
it's like stupid yeah yeah it's Marvel
Marvis what what wow
[Music]
the [__] bankrupt Jack this
70 year old grandma to his left just
watching him work that button just like
oh
like she's getting horny a little bit
imagine the way he just mashing that
thing
or she's just rolling she's just rolling
her eyes elbowing her husband like
remember when you used
and then she's like yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
couple more years of practice but
or I imagine maybe Siva thinks he's
pressing fast but then next to him
that's what I'm saying she's lighting it
up and then her husband even faster yeah
the seven-year-old lady just yeah 40
spins a second Chief in cigarettes
you must be new here
I was more complimented the fact yes
holy [__] her eyes don't even Flinch at
all the colors and [__] just
super mods
watching her balance go up to 100K back
down to zero yeah
oh my God
so no yeah I was complimenting Siva
system the fact that he could get into
his last tournament like to be kind of
to play as much and get some free hotels
and be like dude you've wasted so much
money here we're gonna give you a chance
to win some back yeah it's like all
right yeah okay they like you not only
that but compete against other yeah
Slaughters Slaughters
The Slaughterhouse yeah yeah nice yeah
nice
nice that's crazy yeah so you know so
this is like a World Series of Poker
type thing but for people that yeah for
people over 65 with irregular heartbeat
and [__] chain smokers bionic valves
yeah yeah and stoma yeah Siva was the
youngest guy there was it really no I
don't know okay I should have asked yeah
but he uh he's not a professional
Gambler he's won a huge pot
nuts right yeah I just thought it was so
funny how we were talking about it I'm
sitting here going no dude it works and
you're like how does it work and then
literally 24 hours late not even wasn't
it
[Laughter]
we both drive home and then he texts me
he's like 40 me videos that Steve is
sending of the slot machine and it's
like as big ass wins I'm like yes no
even the first one and it was like a
pretty big win yeah the next one was
even more yeah like holy hell well I
said Cody won and then he goes wow I
could only imagine that pleasure and I
sent it like three more
[Laughter]
what did it say
hand pay oh yeah that's what it was yeah
hand pay is when you win so much you
have to pay tax on it
something that Cody and I have never
experienced on his life you sent me like
seven videos yeah hand paid God damn
never felt that Joy
Cody just sad in an arrow on
[__] hand pay WOW